[Musique]
on est tous bombardé deux chiffres
depuis le début de la pandémie de
chiffres mais aussi de tableau
comparatif dont il faut parfois se
méfier de plus en plus de gens remettent
en question la gravité de la coved 19 en
comparant le nombre de morts causés par
cette maladie avec d'autres causes de
décès à la base de ces comparaisons
boiteuses des tableaux qui ne donne pas
un portrait tout à fait juste de la
situation
le premier problème de ces tableaux et
que les données présentées sur l'impact
du nouveau coronavirus sont inexacts
comme le nombre de décès giacobbi 19
augmente rapidement depuis le début de
la pandémie
quelques semaines suffisent pour que les
chiffres soient désuète
alors que les autres causes de décès
sont plutôt stables d'une semaine à
l'autre
le professeur antoine flahault directeur
de l'institut de santé globale de la
faculté de médecine de l'université de
genève en suisse note qu'on n'est pas
encore à la fin de l'année 2020 donc les
gens qui ont parlé de comparaison sur
une année entière sur des gens qui font
l'hypothèse que la cobi 19 ne
reviendrait plus à partir du mois de mai
ce qui est loin d'être avérée comme on
le sait tous un autre tableau daté du 9
mars dont un portrait encore plus faux
si la pandémie de covè 19
il compare le nombre des décès
quotidiens dans le monde du à
différentes maladies infectieuses on y
prétend que le coronavirus entraînerait
56 morts par jour c'est faux entre le 22
janvier le 21 mai 2020 le corps d'un
virus affaires moyenne 2789 morts par
jour ce qui le place presque au chemin
des maladies infectieuses au plus fort
de la pandémie on a même compté jusqu'à
huit mille 429 décès en une seule
journée
une autre image virale compare le nombre
de décès de la suède qu'imposer peu de
mesures de prévention avec le nombre de
décès au québec
cette image comparative suggère que le
confinement aurait été contre-productif
une conclusion erronée selon
l'épidémiologiste nimâ machouf qui
soulignent le fait que plusieurs
facteurs différents si la suède du
québec sur elle il faut plutôt comparer
la suède à ses voisins scandinaves où
les conditions sont similaires
en faisant cette comparaison on voit que
la suède compte dix fois plus de
victimes de la kobe 19 que ses pays
voisins alors que sa population n'est
que deux fois plus élevé pour plus de
détails sur ce dossier n'hésitez pas à
consulter l'article signé bouchra wathiq
sur notre site web
n'oublie pas derrière notre groupe
facebook écoutez notre émission diffusée
dès samedi et dimanche sur ici a dit
salut
[Musique]